a man at a gym got his penis stuck in a
five-pound weight yes yes no he didn't
do that with his penis
settle down ladies
you're like when's the next plane to
Germany
no no firefighters had to break the
weight apart to get his penis loose from
it ending up in the wait yeah
well thankfully the guys okay and I
think the lesson is and this is what I
wanted to talk about the lesson is no
matter how embarrassing a situation okay
if you're in danger of being injured you
need to ask for help okay no matter how
embarrassing it is I'm just gonna come
right out and say right now I'm talking
specifically about our stagehand Phil
Phil can you hear me right now Phil yeah
yeah all right I hear you counting you
help
do you need help - no I'm fine Phil I
suspect you're not what exactly are you
doing over there I just like checking on
the fiber-optic cable
no no if that's the case why aren't you
using your hands don't worry about it
Phil I think you need help this is what
I'm talking about I think you need help
no I'm okay you're clearly you're
clearly not okay because I've been told
you call the fire department and in fact
the fire department is getting yeah
they're here right now
no no I didn't that's just my friend
what is your name David it's my friend
David we're going out after the show
okay Dave good to see you Phil you're
clearly lying you're in a lot of
discomfort there no no I'm not I'm just
[Applause]
my point Phil it's okay just admit you
need help no matter how embarrassing
this situation looks okay fiber optic
looks great gonna fail no for God's
sakes
Phil will you just please the love
of God come out and say it
what were you really doing oh the wall
okay
well we have a we have a terrific show
tonight now Andy Andy
leave the wall alone Andy
[Applause]
you